네 빌사남이 간다 오늘은 대한민국
가장 부촌인 한남동에 와 있습니다
한남동은 오래전부터 자산가 분들이 좀
많이 거주하고 좀 고급스러운 이미지
때문에 mg 세대 분들이 좀 많이
오고 있는데 오늘은 한남동의 역사라는
한남동 상권 그리고 이제 한남동 빌딩
투자의 내용을 가지고 한번 촬영해
보도록
[음악]
하겠습니다네 그래서 한남동은 총네
가지 상권으로 좀 분류해 볼 수 있을
것 같습니다 일단 첫 번째로 북한남
지역 이제 한남동에서 북쪽에 있는
지역을 이제 북한남 지역이라고 하고
그 두 번째는 이제 한남동 카페거리
그니까 꽃대가리 손길이라 불리는 그쪽
인근이 이제 두 번째 상권이라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 세 번째
상권은 순천 항병원 앞쪽 상권 그리고
이제네 번째 상권은 한남 더인 앞쪽
상권이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다네
그래서 첫 번째로 말씀드린 그 북한남
상권 같은 경우에는 주로 이제
직장인들이나 아니면 인근의 이제
주민분들이 이용하는 상권인 것으로 좀
보여지고 보통 저녁에는 북한남
상권보다는 좀 이런 카페 거리나 이런
순천항 병원 이쪽으로 좀 많이 한
것으로 좀 보여집니다 한남동 지역
내에서는 그렇게 매출이 좀 높지 않은
어 그런 곳이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같고 두 번째 그 한남동 카페거리
같은 경우에는 한남동 내에서도 매출이
가장 높은 지역이고 2 30대
여성분들이 좀 많이 오는 곳입니다
그리고 여기는 주 7일 상권으로
토요일 매출이 가장 높았고 여성
비율이 제일 높은 그런 곳이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 그래서 다른
지역과 비교해서도 되게 좀 매출이
높은 것으로 좀 보여지고 있고요
그래서 한남동 내에서 저는 가장 좋은
지역을 뽑으라고 하면은 바로 이쪽
지역이 가장 좋지 않나네 그렇게 보고
있습니다 그리고 이제 세 번째로
승천한 병원 앞쪽 같은 경우에는
거기는 이제 평일에 사람이 더 많아요
그래서 금요일이 사람이 제일 많은 거
같습니다 그래서 거기 일때는 좀
이렇게 유흥 상권이 좀 많이 밀집되어
있고네 그러다 보니까 오픈업 데이터
에 따르면 어 이렇게 30대 남성
비율의 소비가 되게 많다라고
하더라고요 그래서 거기는 좀 이제
유흥 쪽에 좀 많이 발달이 된 거
같고 그리고 마지막 이제 한남도일
앞쪽 상권 같은 경우에는 거기도 이제
금요일 날 매출이 좀 제일 높고
거기는 또 이제 2 30대 여성분들이
좀 많이 오는 것으로 좀 알려져
있습니다 그래서 아마 이제 그
한남도일 주민분들이 거기 앞쪽에 이제
상권을 좀 많이 이용하고 그러다
보니까 좀 되게 고급스러운 그런
카페라 든지 뭐 레스토랑이라는 그런
매장들이 좀 많이 밀집되어 있습니다
그래서 상권 순으로 좀 보자면 여기
카페거리 꼼대 가래 손길이면 쪽이
가장 매출이 좋고 그리고 이제 상권이
가장 좋고 그다음 이제 순천항 병원
그다음 한남도일 앞쪽 그다음 이제
북한남 어이 순으로 이어진다고 보시면
될 거 같습니다네 오늘 매각사례 하나
설명드릴 건데 어 2020년 그
코로나가 한창일 때 251억 이게
매입했던 사례가 있는데 그게 이제
매입한지 한 6개월 만에 매각을
했더라고요 그래서 매각한 금액이 무려
320억 원에 매각을 했습니다 그래서
이거 같은 경우에는 거의 6개월 만에
뭐 지금 남은 차익만 봐도 뭐 취득세
이런 거 감안해도 대략 한 65억
정도 되는데 여기서 이제 법인으로
매입 했더라고요 그래서 법인이 세금이
이제 22% 세금을 뺀다 하더라도 약
한 50억 정도의 차익이 좀 발생됐을
정말이 6개월 만에 50억이 진짜
엄청 큰 돈인데 그래서요 사례 같은
경우에는 순천항 병원 쪽에서도 좀
자리가 제일 좋아요 그래서 자 전면도
되게 넓고 좀 당장의 임대 수익보다는
그 매가 대비 아마 수익률은 그렇게
많이 나오지 않을 것 같아요 근데
수익률보다는 거기 일대가 아무래도
재개발 이슈도 있고 뭐 투자 가치도
높았기 때문에 좀 그런 점에서 좀
매입하지 않았나 그렇게 좀 예상을
하고 있습니다 근데이 사례 같은
경우에는 사실 그때 당시가 기준
금리가 0.5% 있거든요 그래서 진짜
말도 안 되는 금리 있고 빌딩 담보
대출로 만약에 빌린다 하더라도 뭐
2% 대도 나오고 진짜 제 무 제표
괜찮으면 1% 대도 나오던 어 그런
시기였습니다 그래서 아마 시기상 좀
그렇게 좀 좋지 않았나네 그렇게
예상을 하는데 아무튼 6개월 만에
50억 차익을 난 어 사례를 좀
설명드렸습니다 제가네 가지 상권의 좀
단점부터 좀 얘기를 하자면 일단
북한남 같은 경우에는 좀 이렇게
떨어져 있어요 그니까 큰 대로를
넘어서 있어서 외부 사람들이 가기에는
좀 쉽진 않은 거 같습니다 그래서
뭔가 좀 약간 떨어져 있는 상권네
그렇게 보면 될 거 같고 두 번째
카페 거리 같은 경우에는 아무래도
오르막길 내리막길이 좀 심해서 그거에
대한 뭔가 상권 확장이라는 이런게
조금 제한이 있을 거라고 좀 예상을
하고 있고요 그 세 번째 같은
경우에는 유웅 관련된 상건이기 때문에
우리가 생각하는 그런 한남동 느낌의
그런 분위기는 아닌 거 같아요 뭔가
술을 먹는 어 그런 분위기의 뭔가
상권인 거 같고네 번째 이제 한남
더이 앞 같은 경우에도 거기도 좀
이렇게 떨어져 있어요 배로 넘어서
있고 뭔가 외부인들이 가기에는 조금
접근성은 조금 떨어지게 합니다
그러면은 뭐 건물 투자를 어떻게
하냐면 북한남 같은 경우에는 좀 이제
오피스 그니까 그래도 수요가 꽤
많더라고요 어 저희도 실제로 임대를
진행했었는데 오피스 수요가 좀 그래도
괜찮게 많이 있던 곳이고 카페 거리
같은 경우에는 뭐 언덕길이나 이런게
있긴 하지만 거기 인근의 이제 주거용
건물 같은 경우에는 반지하가 이렇게
오픈돼 있는 경우가 많았거든요 그래서
리모델링을 했을 때 뭔가 지하
임대료를 좀 높게 받을 수 있는 그런
장점이 있는 거 같습니다 이제 세
번째 같은 경우에는 이제 유흥
상권이나 이런게 좀 많긴 하지만 거기
일대가 재개발 이슈가 있는데 거기가
딱 붙어 있거든요 그래서 만약에 이제
거기 개발했을 경우에는 제일 영향을
많이 받는 어 그런 곳이라고 보면 될
거 같고 그리고 더 같은 경우에는
거기 인근이 이제
더일리 레스토랑들이 좀 많이 있는데
외부인들이 좀 안 오긴 하지만 그래도
차를 이용해서 좀 많이 오기도
하거든요네 그래서 발레도 되게 잘 돼
있고 그래서 조금 떨어져 있긴 하지만
뭔가 그들만의 상권인 그런 느낌
때문에 임대료 수준도 좀 되게 높은
거 같습니다 아 그래서 저는 한남동
전망을 되게 좀 좋게 보고 있고
상권이 좋으려면 주 7위 상권에 2
30대 여성분들이 많아야 되는데
그거와 딱 부합하게 한남동 상권이
그렇게 활발하게 좀 되어 있고 그리고
주변에 뭐 재개발이라는 그다음에 이제
최고가 주택들이 또 많이 있거든요
그래 그분들이 이용하기에 뭔가 되게
고급스러운 이미지에도 맞고 그래서
저는 한남동 상권은 계속 좀 좋아질
것 같습니다 이제 거기에 있는
빌딩들을 매입하는게 이제 거기 최고가
주택에 사시는 분들이 다
매입하시나요
가로스 길이나 로데오 건물 보면은
앞구정 현대 사시는 분들이 또 많이
있거든요 그것처럼 한남동 이쪽은
그래도 탄탄한 그런 수요들이 많이
받쳐 주기 때문에 저는 어 투자
가치는 좀 계속 오를 만한 어 그런
곳이라고 좀 생각합니다 그래서
여러분들도 한남동 상권을 좀 주의깊게
지켜보시면 좋을 거 같고요 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고 제가 좀 한남동
권이랑 좀 이렇게 매각된 사례라
이렇게 좀 앞으로의 전망에 대해서 좀
말씀드렸는데 어 여러분들 좀 어떻게
보셨나요 어 그래서 저는 개인적으로
한남동 투자 가치는 어 용산구
내에서는 되게 좀 괜찮다라고 생각을
합니다 그래서 여러분들도 계속 좀
한남동 상권을 좀 지켜보시면 좋을 거
같고 제가 어찌됐든 계속 이렇게 뭐
여러 상권을 가고 있으니까 만약에
궁금하신 상권이 있다라고 하시면 어
댓글로 원하시는 상권 남겨 주시면
제가 또 찾아가서 또 이렇게 영상을
촬영하도록 하겠습니다 여러분들 빌딩은
산합 가보겠습니다
[음악]